[Music]
my name is Gail Banks and I'm a
volunteer and director of The Gap shop
and my name's Lou Parker I'm the manager
of the shop and and that is Gap in the
market on broadstairs High Street we've
been on the High Street for seven years
we sell you know everything from you
know lovely ladies tops and dresses you
know to you know High Street Brands to
really premium brands of ladies clothing
as well lots of bric-a-brac collectors
items lots of shoes we cater for men and
ladies so yeah everything's donated to
us which is absolutely amazing
the Gap in the market shops as Lou said
started seven years ago because the Gap
project was just doing so well it was so
successful needed to expand but we
didn't have the funding the idea of
having a shop in the High Street came up
the first five years were tough really
it's a new business but the last few
years have been fantastic and we have
been able to gift a lot of money to the
project so that they can start up new
schemes within the Gap project
we've got 25 volunteers at the moment
um but we really really need more but
the great thing about our team is the
variety of people who come it's not just
retired people who are looking for
something to do we've had a lot of young
people who can come on Saturdays or
during the week we ask people for three
hours a week morning or afternoon and
it's not just about working in the shop
you know being a sales assistant
dressing the windows side and start we
do stuff outside of the shop as well so
you know Christmas we're having a
Christmas carvery and a quiz a bit of
live music so it really is a team of
friendships but everyone's got one thing
in common as that is really passionate
about about the shop
foreign
if you don't use these places they won't
be here you need to support your local
High Street otherwise it won't survive
you know these are small businesses
local people they've got families and
you can get some really you can get some
really good deals on the High Street you
see a lot of local people and we're all
about that we are a community shop and
we're supporting a community project
it's all about
done it and particularly broadstairs